It was arguably the most
unforgettable moment
in the billion dollar
blockbuster, Barbie.
It is literally impossible to be a woman.
We have to always be extraordinary,
but somehow we're always doing it wrong.
You have to never get old,
never be rude,
never show off, never be selfish,
never fall down,
never fail, never show fear,
never get out of line.
I'm just so tired of watching myself
and every single other woman
tie herself into knots
so that people will like us.
Yes, the perpetual double standards.
America Ferrera there with a raw, honest
and inspirational assessment
of the impossible standards.
Women are held to.
With awards season
shifting into high gear
after the Golden Globes,
where Barbie won for cinematic
and box office achievement.
I sat down with Ferrera here in L.A.
to talk about this Barbie's
subversive feminism
and Oscar controversy.
America Ferrera, welcome to the program.
Thank you.
How surprised were you at the huge impact
that monologue had
Your speech in Barbie,
which was already such a successful film?
It was amazing to see how it hit
the audiences
and what the responses were.
I know that when I
when I first read the script,
everything before and after
and including the monologue,
we have to always be extraordinary.
But somehow we're always doing it wrong.
I know that I was just blown away
and it was all just so unexpected and.
And as a woman, I was just so excited,
you know, that.
That, you know, it's the Barbie movie
that no one asked for,
that no one thought we needed,
you know, And.
Kind of subversively seriously feminist.
Yes. Yes. And nobody believed that.
They thought it was just going to be
another telling of a
of a really incredible doll
that so many millions of girls
around the world played with. Yeah.
And it could have been that,
you know, it
very easily could have been something
bright and fun and exciting
and probably would have
made a lot of money and been successful.
But.
But what Gretta and her partner
Noah, did with the script
and then Greg as the director
creating this world.
It was so generous
and it was so exciting.
And, you know, as an adult woman, mother,
you know, to get
a third of the way into the script
and then to meet this
this adult real flawed,
you know, insecure, but having ambition.
Woman like struggling to be,
you know, so many things
to see so many different people.
It was so exciting to feel like
we had a voice in the story
and you know, that
I felt that way
independent of being
asked to be a part of it
just as a woman in the world.
So we played a little bit of that speech.
What would you say
is the standout line,
the stand out message that you wanted
and maybe now really want
even more to get across to
young girls and even men?
Yeah, I mean,
that's the
other piece of the generosity of this
is that Greta and no one did It
didn't only make
Cam the butt of the joke.
Everyone's the butt of a joke.
At some point,
they gave him a real reason
to be in the story.
They they
they created a foil to the
to the women's journey.
To the journey about femininity
and had this whole beautiful journey
about masculinity
and what it means for this character
that Ryan Gosling
obviously played
with, like Marlon Brando commitment.
It was so a mix. Yes.
And so amazing to watch.
I do feel like the message
is deeply universal.
It's not just for women
or just for girls.
It's like we all lose
when we live inside of these boxes.
Literal and imagined,
and that we all are yearning
and wanting to be more than the boxes
that we get stuck in
and we keep ourselves in.
There's some controversy.
Judd Apatow,
the wonderful,
you know, film and comedic personality,
has basically said,
you know, the idea of of the academy,
the academy Awards,
putting Barbie in the adapted
screenplay category for the Oscars
instead of original screenplay,
he said on Twitter X
that it's insulting to writers.
Do you agree?
You know, I'm not a writer
and I don't know the rules
and the ins and outs of the academy.
I think that it
you know, that there was no story before.
And Greta
got her hands on this
to think
that anyone handed anything to Greta,
if anything,
this IP and the fact that it was Barbie
was a bigger obstacle
towards creating an exciting new kind
of groundbreaking story and character.
It's wholly and completely original,
and I think that it should have been
in the category that the writers chose
to submit it in.
That said, I'm
not an Academy rules expert and I.
I don't know.
You.
You, I told Mark Ronson,
the music producer, there's
going to be a before baby and after I.
Did tell him.
So how did the world change before
and after and how did America Ferrera,
his World change?
Oh, wow.
Those are two very big questions.
I mean, I think that
only time will tell
what the
real cultural impact and individual
impact for for people watching this film
can have.
I know that as an artist,
it is so deeply inspiring.
It's creativity, it's cinematic artistry,
and also just the rules that it breaks,
you know?
And and I do think that it was
it was that bridesmaid's moment,
you know,
where where
before that
there was an unspoken
acceptance that women weren't funny
and that women's movies
couldn't be funny,
and that if it was a movie about women,
men wouldn't
watch it or other people wouldn't
watch it and it couldn't travel
and it couldn't make money.
And I do feel like
there was a before Bridesmaids
and and after bridesmaids.
And and that's how I felt
when I read the script
when we were making the movie.
There is going to be a before
and an after, and it's
going to be
about
opening people's ideas
of what's possible in storytelling
and what we're capable of.
And the women's and girls
stories actually do sell. Yes.
And that and that.
Their stories are our stories.
I grew up my whole life
wanting to be Tom Hanks.
You know,
I grew up putting myself in men's shoes
as a child.
Like, of course, men can do the reverse.
Of course, people of all genders
can see themselves in each other.
It's it's so simple,
but it's also a choice to place value
in those stories.
And and Gretta and Margot
took a huge swing and got people
to take a massive bet.
And and they delivered.
America Ferrera, thank you so much.
Thank you.